Jordan for you to be turning 21 I've
known you forever and I'm so proud of
you and the woman that you have grown
into and that you're growing into and to
see you guys just stick together and be
best friends through thick and thin it's
such a blessing congratulations on
everything and this will be a huge
success
yikes Khloe Kardashian gives an awkward
toasts wealth awkward now that is -
Jordan woods and Kylie Jenner in a sneak
peak of Sunday's Keeping Up with the
Kardashians of course Jordan woods who
is or was Kylie Jenner's BFF was caught
in the middle of a cheating scandal back
in February with Khloe's been boyfriend
Tristan Thompson
Tristan might love me whatever that
means he has no respect for me
whatsoever the drama will unfold on this
season of the reality show and it seems
like we're approaching the beginning it
just sucks it has to be so public I'm
not just a TV show like this is my life
we film everything and we try to show as
much as we can in 44 minutes once a week
kind of went at horse show so we tried
to get in there as much as we can that
we know that everybody will love and
it's just so good after Chloe kicked
Tristan to the curb she initially blamed
Jordan for breaking up her family but
has since placed blame solely on her ex
he just kissed me and like a tongue kiss
like a pepper on the lips
Peck was like oh no it was like a kiss
on the lips but no tongue kiss no making
out God and nothing and I don't think
that he's wrong either because I allowed
myself to be in that position and when
alcohols involved people make you know
dumb moves or people get caught up in
the moment or who knows I really just
heard so many more people by not
telling the truth
[Applause]
[Music]